got this yummy treat
oh my goodness leroy
oh my gosh lieutenant dan
come here hey danny
hi i'm vanessa a pastry chef and i'm
also a crazy dog mom for my little
puppy's birthday i made homemade dog
safe birthday treats and i'm going to
show you how to make them for your own
fur baby let's get started of course you
know your fur baby best so use
discretion when serving just in case
they might have a sensitive tummy so
what we're going to do is we're gonna
add our ingredients to our stand mixer
we're gonna add half a cup of peanut
butter and four eggs
and next we're gonna add a cup and a
half of sweet potato puree you wanna
blend this nice and smooth before you
add your flour
okay this looks perfectly smooth enough
for us to add our six cups of whole
wheat flour this looks a little too
sticky and we want a nice soft ball to
be able to roll it out so i'm going to
add a little bit more whole wheat flour
to get it to a nice consistency you
don't have to use all six cups if you
see that it's coming together with less
amount of flour
this mixture has had enough
perfect this is a nice soft ball of
dough not too sticky it all came
together really well i only ended up
using about four cups so you can adjust
as needed okay this is a beautiful piece
of dough i'm so excited it's nice and
soft great consistency i'm gonna use a
little bit of flour for my board and a
little bit of flour on top
so i'm gonna roll this out to about half
an inch thick so we've got our dog
biscuit cutter because obviously and
this should yield about two dozen dog
biscuits these are so freaking cute
i love this what a fun idea for like
birthday parties definitely great gift
ideas for your dog friends or your
friends that have dogs
[Laughter]
when these bake these are going to be
kind of firm like a traditional dog
biscuit this peanut butter smells so
good i want one of these for myself and
while we're waiting i'm going to show
you how to jazz it up with a peanut
butter drizzle sauce for our peanut
butter drizzle it's just half a cup of
peanut butter
and two tablespoons of coconut oil we're
going to melt this down on a medium heat
on the stove until it all comes together
so this is more about melting than it is
about cooking it looks about done so i'm
gonna check on our dog biscuits and then
we'll finish our dog treats i let them
cool to the touch for about 15 minutes
we've got our biscuits we've got our
peanut butter drizzle now let's decorate
so our peanut butter drizzle is nice and
cool great consistency for drizzling
this drizzle just kind of jazzes up your
biscuits a little bit gives it a real
michelin feel this is so cute
these biscuits look so irresistible if
your dog doesn't love these you need to
take him to the vet a fork is also easy
to use if you want to have that nice
professional drizzled look all righty
these are done we've got our first treat
for our puppy party next we're gonna
make a carrot peanut butter spice cake
so we're gonna start by mixing our dry
ingredients together we've got one cup
of whole wheat flour one teaspoon of
cinnamon one teaspoon of ginger and a
teaspoon and a half of baking powder
we're just going to mix these together
until they're nice and incorporated so
next we're going to work on our wet
ingredients we have two eggs we have one
third of a cup of applesauce three
tablespoons of honey one tablespoon of
molasses half a cup of peanut butter and
we're also going to add a quarter of a
cup of vegetable oil we're going to give
this a nice mix so we mix our dry and
wet ingredients separately that way our
dry ingredients are incorporated fully
and we don't over mix our batter okay so
this is nice and mixed now we're going
to combine the two together make sure
that you scrape your sides you want to
get all of your ingredients in your
batter it's going to start to thicken as
you mix it our last ingredient is going
to be one cup of finely grated carrots
which we're gonna fold in so this is
done and keeping in the theme of our
biscuits we have a dog-shaped cake pan
so now we're gonna add our batter into
our dog bone cake pan this has already
been
pre-greased that way it doesn't stick to
the cake pan and it pops right out in a
perfect shape you want to spread it
evenly into the pan that way the cake
bakes evenly just like the dog biscuits
we're gonna put this in the oven on 350
for 20 to 25 minutes and then when we
come back i'll show you how to put the
icing on the cake except that it's
frosting
our dog frosting is two ingredients 16
ounces of cream cheese and three
tablespoons of honey we're gonna give
this a nice paddle so it's nice and
smooth
i'm noticing this isn't the exact
consistency that i want so we're just
going to add a little bit of water to
smooth it out to give it a better
consistency
[Applause]
okay this is perfect let's go get our
cakes and complete our puppy party so
first we're going to decorate our dog
cake i'm gonna get our dog friendly
frosting and put it on top and we're
gonna get some on the sides as well i'm
using a large offset spatula just to
spoon it on top and i'm gonna use a
small offset spatula to get into the
grooves using a small offset spatula is
great for when you're decorating small
cakes when you have different shapes and
different crevices because it's really
going to help you get right into the
details of things i'm doing a sweeping
motion of backwards forwards to evenly
spread my frosting i'm also making sure
that i'm using the frosting to get a
nice even coating on the cake so at my
dog puppy party i coated my cake and
fondant but this is much more at home
cook based base user-friendly so that's
why i definitely recommend using a
buttercream over fondant all right so we
are done i'm just gonna do what we did
with our dog biscuits and just do a fun
peanut butter drizzle
okay so that's it that's our puppy cake
okay guys there we have it we have our
dog friendly cake and of course the
delicious dog biscuit treats now you're
ready to be the perfect dog parents that
you've always dreamed
come here penny
is that yummy
let us know in the comments if you want
to see any more homemade pet recipes and
i'll see you next time oh yes
[Music]
[Music]
you